نحو ازمه سياسيه واجتماعيه يدفع مشروع
تعديل انظمه التقاعد الجمهوريه الفرنسيه
فاصرار ماكرون على تمريره بكل الوسائل حتى
بدون اغلبيه في مجلسي البرلمان يقابله
عناد الشارع واحزاب المعارضه على رفضه
ومن بين الاثمان التي يبدو ان الرئيس
الفرنسي مستعد لدفعها في سعيه الحثيث
لتمرير القانون التضحيه بحكومه اليزابيث
بورن التي تواجه محاوله حجم ثقه من احزاب
المعارضه
اخر الاحزاب المطالبه براس الحكومه كتله
النواب المستقلين بالاضافه الى كتله
التجمع الوطني ويحتاج هؤلاء الى جمع 287
صوتا في البرلمان من اجل اسقاط الحكومه في
جلسه تصويت ستجرى الاثنين وفي حال نجاح
المعارضه في اقناع 30 نائبا من اليمين
المحافظ فستصبح مهمتهم في اسقاط الحكومه
ممكنه وسيفتح هذا الباب امام سيناريوهات
اخرى اما بتشكيل الرئيس حكومه جديده او حل
البرلمان والدعوه الى انتخابات البرلمانيه
في غضون 20 الى 40 يوما سيصعب التكهن في
المناخ الحالي ما ان كانت نتائجها ستكون
لصالح الرئيس وحزبه
وعلى امتداد التاريخ الفرنسي الحديث
فالرئيس مكرون ليس اول رئيس يختبر عناد
الشارع والنقابات عندما يتعلق الامر
بانظمه المعاشات وبالتحديد رفع سن التقاعد
ففي عام 95 من القرن الماضي شله البلاد
لاكثر من ثلاثه اسابيع بعد مشروع مماثل
قدمه الرئيس الاسبق جاك شيراك لتعديل نظام
التقاعد وتحت وطاه المظاهرات اضطر شراك
لسحبه وحل الحكومه وفي سنه 2007 نجح
نيكولا ساكوزي في رفع سن التقاعد الى 62
سنه فيما يعرف بالانظمه الخاصه بعد
مظاهرات عامه البلاد وتوقفت فيها بشكل كلي
خدمات المترو وخطوط السكك الحديديه لكن
ساكوزي اعتمد على تكتيك تفكيك النقبات
والتفاوض معها على حده وهو ما انتهى
بتمرير التعديل لكن الوضع هذه السنه مختلف
تماما فالمشهد النقابي يبدو اكثر توحدا
مما يفاقم من متاعب ماكرون بالاضافه الى
امتعاد الشارع
من ارتفاع التضخم وتدني الخدمات
الاجتماعيه في دوله اعتادت النقابات فيها
على انتزاع مكاسب عبر التظاهر والاحتجاج